la guerre continue entre donald trump et
les réseaux sociaux
snap chatte s'invite dans le conflit qui
oppose déjà twitter et facebook au
président en accusant donald trump
d'incitation à la violence raciale et en
stoppant la promotion de ces
publications
après avoir menacé de les fermer le
locataire de la maison blanche a signé
un décret visant à limiter la protection
de ces plateformes facebook et twitter
pourrait ainsi être plus souvent
poursuivis en justice concernant le
contenu publié par leurs utilisateurs
à l'origine de ce conflit des tweets
sans précédent du président américain
pourtant habitué à ce réseau social les
premiers concernés le vote par
correspondance et ont été signalés avec
la mention vérifier les faits une action
inédite sur un tweet du milliardaire
défendue par le pdg de twitter jack
dorsey cela ne fait pas de nous un
arbitre de la vérité notre intention est
de relier les points des déclarations
contradictoires et de montrer les
informations en litige afin que les gens
puissent juger par eux mêmes une plus
grande transparence de notre part est
essentielle pour que les gens puissent
voir clairement le pourquoi de nos
actions mais c'est un autre tweet qui a
cristallisé la bataille entre twitter et
donald trump
quand les pillages des mares les tirs
commence une phrase lourde de sens
à propos des manifestations après la
mort de georges floyd immédiatement
signalé puis masquée par la plateforme
une situation tendue qui éclabousse
également le réseau social facebook
puisque mark zuckerberg a lui choisi de
ne pas censurer les messages du
président américain le pdg du géant
américain affirme prôner avant tout la
liberté d'expression principe
fondamental de son réseau
personnellement j'ai une réaction
viscérale négatives à ce genre de
rhétorique de division et d'inflammation
mais il m'incombe de réagir non à titre
personnel mais en tant que dirigeant
d'une institution attachés à la liberté
d'expression
un comportement qui suscite
l'incompréhension auprès des salariés de
facebook
ces derniers accusent mark zuckerberg
d'avoir menti sur la censure des posts
incitant à la violence
je ne sais pas quoi faire mais je sais
que ne rien faire n'est pas acceptable
je suis un employé de facebook qui en
total désaccord avec la décision de marc
de ne rien faire concernant les récents
posts de trump qui incite clairement à
la violence
je ne suis pas seul au sein de facebook
il n'y a pas de position neutre sur le
racisme marque à tort et je m'efforcerai
de le faire changer d'avis de la manière
la plus brillante possible je suis fier
d'annoncer qu'à compter de la fin de la
journée je ne serai plus un employé de
facebook
je travaille chez facebook et je ne suis
pas fier de l'image que nous diffusons
la majorité des collègues à qui j'ai
parlé pensent la même chose nous faisons
entendre notre voix
la situation loin d'être résorbé laisse
présager un futur incertain pour les
réseaux sociaux alors que l'élection
présidentielle américaine approche à
grands pas la campagne elle bat son
plein sur les plates formes de quoi se
demander si donald trump a bien choisi
son moment pour entrer en conflit avec
ces géants du numérique